Joe doesn't feel French the son of
Congolese immigrants was born in France
but since the age of eleven he has been
undergoing almost daily identity checks
by the police for him it's a system to
put young people in poor areas in their
place it's almost like they were trying
to make us hate them like they don't
want us young people from the suburbs to
get along with them when the ideas they
say things like hey they're so
condescending push us violently against
the wall and Pat us down earlier this
year a policeman in the Paris suburb was
accused of raping a 22 year old black
man called teal with a police baton over
the past decade at least a dozen people
from the suburbs have died while being
taken into custody
joe vented his anger and helplessness
about the deaths in a rap song called
blunder we are going to smoke the police
he's singing we are going to tame them
it's a call to other young people to
fight back but of course there is
another side to the story we asked the
police if we could ride along with a
patrol in an area like this one but our
request was turned down we were told the
officers didn't want to show their faces
on camera because they were concerned
that that would put them in further
danger Denis Jacob used to work in the
suburbs and is now a spokesman for a
police union in Ocean City to be seen on
attack when I was patrolling in this
area several years ago people would
throw cobblestones at us sometimes even
washing machines or TVs from the 10th
floor challah is for Tina what we do
only quickly I could imagine
now my colleagues are welcomed by
machine-gun fire Mateo police say the
drug trade is flourishing in the suburbs
and that stop and search is often their
only waited
the dealers in check the police say
Joe's song is an incitement to kill
police officers they are pressing
charges
the rapper has asked an anti racism
group to help him with a court case he
could have to pay thousands of euros in
legal fees so not too politically we
think this is a political act they just
want to do people people from the
suburbs as monsters it's the world
upside down they should be trying to
solve the underlying problem if young
people I do talk about this that just
shows that there is a problem and not
that those who speak out are insane Joe
says it is a misunderstanding and that
the police are overreacting
was only available when I say we should
smack them then that's just my way of
speaking at home for example I sometimes
say to my little sister hey give me the
remote control or else make it up but
that doesn't mean I want to kill my
little sister but you tell the court
verdict is due in September but even if
he loses Joe says you will keep on
rapping it seems unlikely that the
police and the young people in Francis
troubled areas will be speaking the same
language anytime soon